[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Wieso sage ich eigentlich immer den gleichen Anfang?
Immer: Ihr seid herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Hallo!
Willkommen in meiner Küche!
Nee, das hört sich nicht so...
Egal.
Wir belassen es bei:
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute wird bei uns gegrillt
und ich möchte euch in diesem Video,
weil ihr immer wieder in den Stories auch nachfragt,
was wir denn immer so grillen,
zeigen, was wir heute machen.
Und zum einen ist es jetzt heute
wie so eine Art Menü,
zum anderen könnt ihr es benutzen,
wenn ihr sagt: "Wir wollen vegan oder vegetarisch grillen."
Denn das meiste wird auf dem Grill zubereitet.
Oder ihr sagt: "Wir wollen ganz klassisch grillen.
Und alles, was du heute hier zubereitest,
ist dann sozusagen eine Grillbeilage."
Also je nachdem, wie viele Personen ihr seid,
was ihr alles zubereitet,
ist es eben eine Beilage oder sogar ein Hauptgericht.
Und ich mache es immer ganz gerne so,
ich mache Dinge, die ich dann auch noch
die nächsten ein, zwei Tage essen kann.
Also, wenn wir freitags oder samstags grillen,
dann haben sonntags auch noch was davon
und es wird einfach alles nicht schlecht
und man hat eben ganz wenig Arbeit damit.
Was wir zuerst immer machen ist Baguette,
magisches Baguette, weil es einfach megaeinfach ist.
Und es ist einfacher, also Brot kaufen zu gehen.
Denn ihr braucht im Prinzip nur etwas Hefe und Zucker,
Wasser, Mehl und Salz.
Das war es.
Das Rezept gibt es schon auf meinem Kanal.
Und ich habe jetzt hier die doppelte Menge.
Ich habe hier die Hefe schon zerbröselt
und gebe sie jetzt mit dem Zucker hier in die Schüssel
– in die Schüssel.
Dann direkt das Wasser dazu.
Und ihr könnt das magische Baguette
entweder ganz klassisch und hell machen
oder ihr könnt sagen, ihr verfeinert es.
Und so machen wir es auch gerne.
Also je nachdem, was ich gerade dahabe.
In der Bärlauchzeit haben wir auch gerne
Bärlauch-Baguette gemacht.
Ihr könnt auch kleine Brötchen daraus machen,
Frühstücksbrötchen zum Beispiel,
Oliven mit dazu geben.
Also da könnt ihr wirklich den Geschmack
komplett umwandeln.
Und, wenn ihr die Zutaten verrührt habt,
kommt im Prinzip nur noch das Mehl dazu.
Und das Besondere ist,
dass man es eben nicht kneten muss.
Also man kann wirklich alles
mit dem Koch- oder Backlöffel verrühren.
Salz kommt auch rein.
Ich gebe auch manchmal gerne Chili dazu,
aber nur in die Hälfte
für die Kinder.
Äh, in die andere Hälfte,
also nicht für die Kinder,
meine ich doch.
Ach, Gott, he!
Gut.
Und heute machen wir,
weil wir gerade Schnittlauch im Garten haben,
Schnittlauch-Baguette.
Also nehmen wir heute Schnittlauch.
Was auch megalecker ist, sind Röstzwiebeln,
getrocknete Tomaten.
Also tobt euch da ruhig aus.
[Musik]
Und ich schabe dann hier so
den Teig am Rand runter,
dass er da einfach nicht so austrocknet.
Dann ist mein Brotteig schon mal gerichtet.
Das Baguette ist sozusagen fast fertig.
Ich decke es jetzt einfach ab
und kann es jetzt bis zu zwei Stunden aufgehen lassen.
Wenn es mal schnell gehen muss,
– so machen wir es meistens –
gebe ich es einfach ohne Deckel
in den Backofen.
Denn da kann ich die Gärstufe einstellen auf 34°C.
Und dann ist das Baguette im Prinzip schon,
also der Teig, schon innerhalb von 30 bis 60 Minuten fertig.
Da ist wirklich einfach nur wichtig,
gar nicht so lange kneten,
wirklich nur rühren
und dann darf der Teig einfach schön aufgehen.
Ihr könnt das auch schon am Tag vorher zubereiten
und dann aber im Kühlschrank aufgehen lassen mit Deckel.
Okay.
Und jetzt geht es bei uns direkt weiter.
Ich richte mal alle Zutaten
und zeige euch, was es heute noch so alles gibt.
[Musik]
Wir brauchen immer so viel Knoblauch
für alles beim Grillen!
Dann gebt ihr einfach die Knoblauchknolle in ein Glas,
verschließt es und schüttelt.
Und dann ist sie geschält.
Huch!
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt als Nächstes die Champignon-Pfanne.
Das mache ich dann immer ganz gerne
in so einem Gusseisenbräter.
Den kann ich nämlich entweder auf dem Herd benützen,
auf der Kochstelle, oder draußen auf dem Grill.
Dafür habe ich jetzt hier 1 Kilo Champignons,
– da könnt ihr weiße oder eben auch dunkle nehmen –
zwei Zwiebeln,
zwei Riesenknoblauchzehen,
etwas Thymian.
Hier habe ich noch Salz, Pfeffer und Chili
und Olivenöl.
Und das lässt sich auch super vorbereiten
und vor allem auch schnell zubereiten.
Also einfach die Champignons halbieren.
[Musik]
Die kann ich jetzt hier auch schon mal reingeben.
Ihr könnt auch alternativ einfach so eine Grillschale benutzen,
die aber eben zu ist, damit das Fett nicht raustropft.
Und die mag ich echt supergerne.
Denn, wenn wir sie nicht komplett aufessen heute,
kann ich sie morgen immer noch essen,
wie so eine Art Antipasti dann auch kalt,
als Salat oder ich mische dann
zum Beispiel Rucola noch mal dazu.
Also die kann man wirklich individuell dann noch mal variieren.
Die Zwiebeln und die Knoblauchzehen schneide ich jetzt auch,
die Zwiebeln einfach in Halbringe
und die Knoblauchzehen in feine Scheiben.
[Musik]
Dann etwas Salz und Chili.
Pfeffer.
Den mahle ich jetzt aber etwas grob.
Ich liebe Zwiebeln, aber ich hasse es, sie zu schneiden.
Olivenöl dazu.
Kurz durchmischen.
Und dann ist die Pfanne schon mal gerichtet
und ich kann mich um die nächste Beilage kümmern
oder um das nächste Gericht.
Majoran oder Oregano oder Thymian,
was auch immer es ist...
Ich glaube, es ist aber tatsächlich
Oregano.
Denn ich habe keinen Majoran angepflanzt.
Es muss Oregano sein.
Das gebe ich erst zum Schluss mit dazu,
damit es einfach jetzt auf dem Grill gleich nicht verbrennt.
Und die Champignon-Pfanne lege ich kurz zur Seite.
Jetzt gibt es als Beilage noch Kartoffeln,
Rosmarinkartoffeln.
Und da habe ich jetzt kleine Kartoffeln
bereits auch gewaschen.
So müsst ihr sie auch nicht schälen.
Und die werde ich jetzt als Nächstes zubereiten,
weil ich die im Ofen vorgare, damit sie auf dem Grill
einfach nicht zu viel Zeit in Anspruch nehmen.
Also ich habe jetzt hier
2 Kilo Kartoffeln,
drei große Knoblauchzehen oder sechs kleine,
etwas Olivenöl,
Rosmarin aus dem Garten
und Salz und Pfeffer.
Ich finde, mehr brauchen Kartoffeln sowieso nicht.
Je nach Größe halbiere ich sie jetzt einfach.
Die kleinen lasse ich jetzt aber so im Ganzen.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier einen Gusseisentopf beziehungsweise eine Pfanne.
Denn den kann ich jetzt vorher in den Ofen schieben
und später einfach auch auf dem Grill benutzen.
Ich benutze es jetzt gleich mit Deckel im Ofen,
damit die Kartoffeln vorgaren,
und später natürlich ohne Deckel,
damit ich das Grillaroma auch in den Kartoffeln habe.
[Musik]
Die Knoblauchzehen auch noch ganz kurz
halbieren oder vierteln.
Ich liebe Knoblauch einfach, wenn er so im Ganzen ist
und dann in Verbindung mit dem Öl.
Und dann backt das oder grillt das
auf dem Herd oder im Backofen
oder auf dem Grill draußen.
Megalecker!
Salz und Pfeffer
und Rosmarin.
Alles vermischen.
Und dann kommt es, wie gesagt, in den Backofen,
wird vorgegart.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal andere Dinge zubereiten und vorbereiten.
Huiuiui!
Das ist eigentlich schon ein Gericht für sich.
Einfach lecker!
Josh, magst du Rosmarinkartoffeln?
>> JOSH: Megagerne!
>> SALLY: Gerne?
Ich finde, das ist einfach so die perfekte Kombination.
Ach, schau dir das Bild an!
Also eigentlich bereitet einfach nur
Kartoffeln zu mit Rosmarin
und fertig.
Und Knoblauch!
Mehr braucht man nicht.
>> JOSH: Und schön einen frischen Joghurtdip dazu.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
So.
Das ist übrigens auch gleichzeitig ein Peeling für die Hände.
So Olivenöl, Salz und Pfeffer.
[Musik]
Bei uns darf Schafskäse auf dem Grill auch nicht fehlen.
Also gibt es jetzt noch Schafskäse.
Ich mache heute übrigens eine riesige Menge,
denn wir essen später alle im Team.
Also nicht wundern, dass hier alles in
kiloweise Menge zubereitet wird.
Normalerweise, wenn wir jetzt nur zu viert sind,
dann mache ich auch echt nur ein Viertel davon.
Okay, manchmal übertreibe ich es trotzdem.
Aber wir haben dann halt drei Tage was davon.
Also ich nehme jetzt dafür
Schafskäse,
rote Zwiebeln,
Knoblauchzehen,
kleine Cocktailtomaten,
Peperoni,
etwas Bergbohnenkraut,
Olivenöl,
Salz und Pfeffer
und kleine schwarze Oliven.
Ja.
Also ich nehme jetzt hier zuerst die
– Tomaten wollte ich sagen –
die Zwiebeln und schneide sie einfach in Halbringe.
Grillen ist so cool,
weil man wirklich alles perfekt vorbereiten kann!
Und Freunde von uns,
bei denen waren wir bis zum letzten Jahr
eigentlich immer jedes Jahr zum Grillen.
Dieses Jahr weiß ich nicht, ob es was wird.
Mal gucken.
Und da war es immer so,
die machen dann immer
Vorspeise, Zwischengang, Hauptspeise
und das sind dann wirklich mehrere Gänge.
Man sitzt dann da und kann
irgendwie vier bis fünf Stunden richtig schön grillen.
Und dann macht es auch, finde ich, noch mehr Spaß,
weil man einfach immer wieder was Kleines isst
und draußen sitzt und schön in der Sonne.
Und ja, ich bereite jetzt gleich alles auf einmal zu,
weil wir im Team hier
alle immer sehr hungrig sind und alles auf einmal wollen.
Aber das eignet sich auch alles hervorragend wirklich,
um eben diese Zwischengänge zu machen.
Da kann man ja wirklich so den Schafskäse vorweg machen
und dann die Kartoffeln als Hauptgang
mit dem Spargel zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Die Zwiebeln jetzt gar nicht so fein,
sondern eher grob schneiden.
Die Knoblauchzehe in Scheiben.
Jetzt kommt hier erst mal alles in eine Schüssel.
Da verrühre ich jetzt nämlich alles,
also auch die Tomaten,
die Peperoni.
Lasst da auch ruhig Zutaten weg, die ihr nicht mögt,
oder nehmt welche dazu, die ihr gerne mögt.
Oliven.
Das kann ich jetzt schön mit dem Olivenöl erst mal verrühren.
Hier noch direkt etwas Pfeffer dazu
und nur ein bisschen Salz.
Denn ich habe ja noch den Schafskäse
und die Peperoni, die ist ja auch würzig.
Bergbohnenkraut,
das zupfe ich so ein bisschen ab.
Und dann kommt es in eine ofen- und grillgeeignete Form.
Ich lasse das jetzt hier drauf
Zack.
Ich nehme jetzt hier diese vier Pfännchen,
damit ich das später dann auf dem Tisch schön verteilen kann.
Aber ihr könnt auch alles in eine Schale geben.
[Musik]
Ich finde, das sieht schon ziemlich cool aus.
Also, wer es vegan machen möchte, gerne so.
Aber mit Schafskäse natürlich auch megamegalecker.
Und vor allem unsere Ela
liebt gebackenen Schafskäse.
Ich weiß, da gibt es eine Öffnung,
aber meine Hände sind gerade fettig.
Und den Käse gebe ich jetzt einfach hier in die Schüssel,
wälze ihn im Rest Fett
und lege ihn dann hier drauf.
Das sind so Gerichte, die schmecken gut
und sie sehen gut aus.
[Musik]
Weil uns grüner Spargel vom Grill megagut schmeckt,
gibt es jetzt für euch das Rezept.
Den habe ich auch schon ganz oft zubereitet.
Und vor allem schmeckt der am nächsten Tag
auch noch richtig gut,
wenn nicht sogar noch besser,
weil er dann richtig durchzieht.
Also ihr könnt ihn kalt essen oder warm essen.
Ist der Hammer!
Dafür nehme ich 1 Kilo grünen Spargel,
etwas Orangensaft,
Olivenöl,
Knoblauch,
Granatapfel,
ganz wichtig,
Salz und Pfeffer
und Pinienkerne.
Hier wird jetzt zuerst einmal
– also den Spargel habe ich schon gewaschen.
Und da entfernt ihr einfach diese holzigen Enden.
Am besten gar nicht wegschneiden, sondern brechen.
Und da, wo er auseinanderbricht,
das ist praktisch der holzige Part.
Den brauche ich nicht.
Und das ist der schöne frische Part.
Dann schneid-
schneidet ihr nicht zu viel weg.
Hast du mich gerade ausgelacht?
>> JOSH: Nein.
Das war Situationskomik.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung!
Hier ist zum Beispiel
– guck mal, das sieht man.
Das komplette Ding ist holzig.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: O Mann! Echt!
Murat macht schon das Feuer.
Dann kann ich hier
die Pinienkerne schon mal in einer Pfanne rösten ohne Fett,
bis sie lecker duften.
So bekommen sie einen besseres Aroma.
Einfach immer wieder so ein bisschen schwenken.
Und dann kann ich schon mal die Marinade zubereiten.
Ich nehme jetzt den Granatapfel.
Und nicht durchschneiden,
sondern erst mal nur
[Scheppern]
halbieren.
Das war der Murat.
Ist dir gerade ein Messer auf den Fuß gefallen?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also nur außen die Schale einritzen.
So.
Und jetzt einfach in die Hand nehmen
und mit einer Schöpfkelle
oder einer Zitruspresse draufschlagen.
Und dann fallen die Kerne raus.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Da jetzt Orangensaft dazu.
Olivenöl.
Voll die Sauerei vorhin hier gemacht.
Aber ich lasse es jetzt.
Ich putze es gleich weg.
Dann den Knoblauch natürlich in Scheiben.
Ich habe überall Knoblauch drin.
Aber zumindest essen wir alle davon.
Dann stört es den anderen nicht.
Und es hält Vampire weg.
Ja.
Dann Salz und Pfeffer.
Ein bisschen schwenken
oder rühren.
Jetzt haben die Pinienkerne ein bisschen Farbe bekommen.
Die kommen jetzt hier noch ganz warm dazu.
Und fertig.
Jetzt muss ich im Prinzip nur noch
den Spargel auf dem Grill grillen.
Also gar nicht lange, der darf ruhig bissfest bleiben.
Ist ja anders als weißer Spargel.
Und dann kommt er einfach mit in diese Marinade.
Einen habe ich noch.
Einen noch.
Und zwar einen warmen Tomatensalat.
Und dann reicht es auch, glaube ich.
Denn ansonsten
sprengt es wieder völlig den Rahmen.
Einen warmen Tomat-
Toma-
Tomatensalat
aus Cocktailtomaten,
Olivenöl,
Knoblauch natürlich,
Senfkörnern,
Pfeffer.
Eine Zitrone.
Da unbedingt darauf achten,
dass auch die Schale zum Verzehr geeignet ist!
Denn ich brauche auch die Zitronenschale.
Salz
und, wenn ihr möchtet, Chili.
Das könnt ihr, wenn ihr jetzt
keinen Platz mehr auf dem Grill habt,
auch gerne auf dem Herd zubereiten.
Dann habt ihr einfach so
einen schönen warmen Tomatensalat.
Ich gucke jetzt gleich, wie es draußen passt.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr es in mehreren Gängen macht,
dann könnt ihr alles auf dem Grill zubereiten.
Ansonsten nehmt ihr auch Backofen und den Herd mit dazu.
Olivenöl habe ich jetzt hier schon in meiner Pfanne.
Dann nehme ich die Knoblauchzehe.
Also wir sind Knoblauchliebhaber.
Ich hoffe, ihr auch.
Bringt halt voll den Geschmack.
Die Knoblauchzehe kommt jetzt hier rein.
Wenn ihr es jetzt drinnen auf dem Herd zubereitet,
könnt ihr gerne die Knoblauchzehe
schon mal ein bisschen rösten.
Ich brauche es jetzt hier an der Stelle nicht.
Dann kommen die gewaschenen Tomaten hier rein,
einfach im Ganzen.
Am besten vorher noch ein bisschen abtrocknen.
Aber ich mache das jetzt so.
So.
Das ist schon mal Part eins.
Und dann mache ich hier jetzt das Dressing rein.
Da kommen jetzt die Senfkörner dazu,
Pfeffer,
etwas Salz.
Jetzt die Zitronenschale abreiben und dazu geben.
Dann den Saft.
Perfekt!
Das ist also das Dressing.
Und die Tomaten werden jetzt
mit dem Olivenöl und Knoblauch schön gegrillt.
Und das Dressing kommt dann später
über die warmen Tomaten.
Die Chili, die nehme ich auch mit dazu.
Die könnt ihr nehmen, müsst ihr aber nicht.
Aber so ein bisschen Chili rein, so eine Schärfe ist schon gut.
Aber ich glaube, ich serviere die einfach separat.
Dann kann sich jeder selber
Chili dazu geben oder eben auch weglassen.
So.
Und dann ist es jetzt fertig.
Ich mache jetzt gleich das Brot fertig.
Alles andere ist gerichtet.
Und der Murat soll schon mal anfangen,
den Spargel zu grillen.
Ich habe den Teig jetzt
zum Schluss gerade noch mal kurz abgedeckt,
weil ich ihn schon aus dem Ofen rausgeholt habe.
Und jetzt kann ich einfach zwischendurch mal
das Baguette zubereiten.
Entweder macht ihr jetzt sechs große Baguette
oder ihr nehmt etwas kleinere Förmchen.
Ihr könnt auch Brötchen machen.
Ihr könnt auch komplett ohne Baguetteform arbeiten.
Wichtig ist, ihr nehmt jetzt am besten so ein Blech
ganz viel Mehl drauf.
Denn der Teig ist ja sehr flüssig.
Und den kippe ich da jetzt drauf.
Wow, riecht der lecker nach Schnittlauch!
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach
die doppelte Menge des Grundrezepts gemacht,
was bereits existiert in meiner App
oder auf dem Blog.
Und hier jetzt auch Mehl oben drüber.
Denn ihr formt den jetzt auch gar nicht mit den Händen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier so kleine Brötchen-/Baguetteförmchen,
aber auch große.
Also eigentlich hätte ich jetzt gerne nur diese kleinen gemacht,
aber ich habe nur zwei Bleche davon.
Deswegen nehme ich noch die großen.
Jetzt wirklich gar nicht großartig den Teig bewegen
und einfach in die Förmchen reinlegen.
Dürfte eigentlich aufgehen.
Ja.
Dann werden es schöne dicke Baguette,
so kleine Mini-Baguette.
Und, wenn ihr sie ohne dieses Blech backt,
könnt ihr sie zum Beispiel so
einfach auf das Lochblech legen.
Und dann backen sie eben ohne Form.
Das geht auch.
Aber so bekommen sie einfach von unten
schon mal diese typische Baguetteform.
[Musik]
So sehen sie jetzt super aus!
Und die nehme ich jetzt noch hierein.
Perfekt!
Und dann direkt sie in den heißen Backofen
bei Heißluft 240°C oder Umluft
oder Ober-/Unterhitze
am besten mit Dampfstoß.
Ansonsten nehmt ihr einfach ein Schälchen mit Wasser
und stellt es dazu.
Und dann sind gleich die Baguette fertig!
[Musik]
Und das übrige Mehl kommt einfach wieder zurück.
Damit aber keine Teigreste drin sind,
einfach kurz durchsieben.
Dann habt ihr da auch nichts verschwendet.
[Musik]
Also den Spargel immer einfach nur schön bissfest garen,
wirklich nur zwei, drei Minuten
oder auch vier, fünf wie Murat.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Aber ich mag das noch so leicht...
>> SALLY: Ja, der muss Biss haben.
>> MURAT: Der muss Biss haben. Genau.
Der darf nicht zu durch sein.
>> SALLY: Und dann kommt da gleich die Marinade drüber.
>> MURAT: Das sind wirklich nur ein paar Minuten.
Aua!
>> SALLY: Ihr könnt den auch gleich noch kleinschneiden.
Aber ich lasse ihn, glaube ich, jetzt erst mal im Ganzen.
So.
Los, Murat! Los, Murat!
>> MURAT: So.
Fertig.
>> SALLY: Und ich gebe dir gleich was.
Und zwar
die Kartoffeln.
Die sind schon vorgegart.
>> MURAT: Zu dem anderen drauf?
>> SALLY: Jetzt schön den Deckel drauf,
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: dass es so ein bisschen Raucharoma bekommt.
>> MURAT: Deckel.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Die Champignon-Pfanne
wird jetzt auch einfach gegrillt,
bis sie gar ist.
Da gebe ich jetzt auch zuerst den Deckel drauf.
Dann gart es ein bisschen schneller.
Und immer wieder schön umrühren.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir fertig!
Jetzt ist alles bereit
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: und wir können essen.
>> SALLY: Und, wie gesagt, das meiste...
Hallo?!
Wir warten jetzt auf alle!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Wie gesagt, das meiste,
gerade die Champignons, die Tomaten,
der Spargel, die Kartoffeln,
kann man auch alles noch morgen essen,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: wenn was übrig bleibt.
Aber eigentlich...
Murat, warte auf unsere Gäste!
>> MURAT: Ich habe so Hunger!
>> SALLY: Also auf das Team,
auf unser Team.
Also, wie gesagt, die Vorbereitung ist hier alles.
Und jetzt haben wir alle Hunger und essen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe jetzt eigentlich erwartet,
dass du sagst: "Was?! Wo ist das Fleisch?
Wo ist das Fleisch?"
>> MURAT: Nee.
Aber ich mag zum Beispiel Spargel als super Fleischersatz.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wirklich!
Und ich bin wirklich ein Fleischesser! Ich liebe es!
Es wäre auch jetzt cool gewesen, ein Rumpsteak zu haben
oder ein Entrecôte oder ein Filet oder...
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
Können wir das nicht noch alles machen?
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also hier könnt ihr wirklich super vegetarisch grillen
oder sogar vegan grillen.
Also bis auf den Schafskäse ist alles sogar vegan.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ihr könnt aber auch sagen:
"Ich nehme jetzt die Champignon-Pfanne oder die Tomaten
und mache dann eben noch Fleisch dazu."
Also, ja, so eine kleine Anregung für euch.
Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und wir essen jetzt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Macht es gut! Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Okay, wir können essen!
[Musik]
>> DENNIS: Als wir jetzt das erste Mal gegrillt haben,
war es natürlich extrem schwer.
Das ganze Fleisch.
Alles hat da gerochen.
Und oh, krass, diese Gerüchte!
Gegrillte Spieße et cetera.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich vermisse nichts!
Du kannst vegan genauso gut grillen wie mit Fleisch!
Das ist gar kein Problem!
Go vegan!
[Musik]